after six weeks of wild intense and yes
at times shocking testimony in the
Johnny Depp Amber Heard trial it all
came down today welcome to Entertainment
Tonight Michelle Turner is off after
just three days of deliberations the
jury ends a stunning win to Johnny Depp
grateful so grateful to the jury
corporations
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes
basically this verdict says that they
completely do not believe Amber Heard
which the reason that's shocking to me
is because to a lot of people watching
this it seemed like this was a mutually
abusive relationship Amber looked down
while the verdict was read and walked
out of the courthouse with her sister
Whitney both Johnny and Amber released
statements within seconds of the verdict
Johnny wrote the jury gave me my life
back I am truly humbled Amber said the
disappointment I feel today is beyond
words we the jury award compensatory
damages in the amount of 10 million
dollars we the jury award punitive
damages in the amount of five million
dollars
the judge modified those punitive
damages down to 350 000 per Virginia's
cap Amber did win one of her three
claims against Johnny and was awarded
two million dollars entertainment lawyer
Mitra ahurian says Amber was fighting an
uphill battle people of course did not
like her but but is that enough for jury
to say that she actually did was not
abused even one time because that's what
this verdict says
as for why Johnny wasn't in the
courtroom a source tells E.T he had
previously scheduled work commitments
and watched from the UK of course
Amber's spokesperson used Johnny's
absence as an opportunity to take a shot
telling E.T your presence shows where
your priorities are Johnny Depp plays
guitar in the UK while Amber Heard waits
for a verdict in Virginia Depp is taking
his snickering and lack of seriousness
on tour
last night Johnny rocked the stage for a
third night in a row
[Applause]
Johnny's ex-girlfriend Kate Moss was
snapped leaving the concert she
testified on his behalf exactly one week
ago no he never pushed me kicked me
all through me town and he says
okay nice to meet you fans were freaking
out about the wild possibility of a
rekindled romance tweeting imagine if
they got back together with the verdict
in a lot of people are wondering what's
next I live in Yucca Valley California
the 36 year old is expected to retreat
to the California desert town where
she's been raising her baby girl about
two hours from La her future in
Hollywood could be challenging
especially as a petition to have her
removed from Aquaman 2 has almost
reached its Target with more than 4.4
million signatures and Johnny he's
leaning into his music when I was a kid
all I dreamed about was becoming a
famous rock star
in court he said he was reluctant to
pursue that dream after rocketing to
stardom on 21 Jump Street I hated the
idea to just to become what they wanted
me to become which was a you know
Teen Idol
the actor who plays guitar in dior's
campaign for Savage is expected to keep
riding a wave of popularity according to
one report a bottle of the cologne he
endorses was sold every three seconds in
2021. sales reportedly Rose in
popularity in April the same month the
trial started Johnny wanted this case to
clear his name he was clear from the
start that he brought this lawsuit to
tell his side of the story and he wanted
cameras in the courtroom so that the
public could see that he was also a
victim here and that much of what Amber
Heard was saying was not true
foreign